And here you can see
all the numbers
for the EU countries compared.
Gosh, that’s a lot of numbers!
Did you put all of that together?
No, they’re from the
EU Publications Office portal.
Okay, then we can trust
the information.
But there are so many numbers.
There are also graphics
to display data.
That’s nice!
Well, look at this for example:
when you look at the document,
it offers you more information
on the same topic.
Is this also in Spanish?
- Of course!
Is the text also available in Dutch?
Ja, actually in all 24 EU languages.
Well, this data looks great,
but can we use it for our app?
Yes, we can use it and…
it’s for free.
You can find lots of information
about the EU
and what it does on
the EU Publications portal:
laws, research, open data,
publications and more.
It’s child’s play.